yeah luck against a legend ok let's go
for the kernel corn again I recently
completely am got murdered in descent is
opening he n blitz with the exchange
variation it's not the most dangerous of
lines actually but that proved very
effective ok now we've got something
entirely different the Bronstein laws in
variation where um hmm where blackham
has got those doubled pawns and it's got
a nice compact structure though and
sometimes even chances to UM to gain
some play on the G farm the surf
fianchetto setup is one of the better
lines and i'm not sure if if I played
this correctly I maybe confuse some some
muth orders hmm yeah yeah it's not
really a threat at the moment I can play
Queen a five to recover but I think I
need to I need to move the bishop at
some point uh-huh is this really a
sustained restore known okay let's just
attack b 2 and so on maybe he's
frightened oh he is very much even be
three years I really weird move the Sun
this should spoil has cancelled
I mean bishop d 224 cannot be the the
thing you want and King f1 long castles
also looks really weird I mean I've got
a 54 c 5 or some some moves coming
Bishop e3 odds already was on but I
wanted to get get cancelled maybe I
could have played bishops III even just
mopping up the d4 pawn but that I don't
think it's necessary to do that them and
simply this position done looks really
weird for wide ok so here I'm pretty
much leaves the deform porn on pre here
I can take it I mean it's not not a
problem but maybe there's something else
that I could take a try yo are ok cannot
castle as mentioned and the deep onus is
really weak I one life something like
this bishops III let's start with this
and if he goes I expect rook t1 yeah
Group D 1 and then I was thinking maybe
I can play a move like we to be five
which exchanges Queens and maybe leads
to him a decent endgame try that come on
it's interesting I mean maybe it is bad
because the King position calls form we
are letting Queen so by keeping twins on
and maybe I've got some play against
this point it could be interesting he
goes d5 okay if he goes d phi by gunite
b6
okay okay peace god Bishop to e7
possibilities hmm ok let's try to
exchange this Bishop with Bishop to c7 I
know it looks ugly but I want to prevent
him from playing at the seaport we will
at any stage try to isolate this porn in
a way
if the office might be risking all of
this it's also got h5 all the time I
would have played h5 already yeah and
this some looks this doesn't look so
great I can get noisy foreign but even
Bishop e3 ff5 still one Bishop a shrimp
oh man maybe it's still okay i mean i
don't really see at the moment what what
big thing why this is doing now I think
it was very very shaky and probably bad
maybe it still is I don't know he still
has got yeah I'm the rook coming in and
i thought this um this shouldn't be too
bad the night on only five just keeps
the pivotal position together and dumb
okay can take care something but I've
got got counter place yet f porn
so even though isn't this even good for
black I mean how does he protect the
poor now I mean rooks it too is a big
threat yeah exactly and how to proceed
now this is this is better for black now
of it how to proceed maybe maybe rook
rook over to age to invade on the second
Ryan cam and the bishop can always drop
back he wants to go Bishop to c4 maybe
yeah okay um I'm pinning this so the
King needs to go to this awkward
position and now I've got Brook h2
coming rook edge 2 and then invade with
the king that's also made threats with
that when the king is only three of them
there that's made in them brooke h1 and
so on yeah this is nice now the king
will be excellent only three hmm
interesting move okay don't don't have
enough time to figure that out
okay if if i go here he's got two groups
e threesome need to go get to go back
time morning check check yeah getting
getting the pawns yeah it's the draw
unfortunately even though even a
positioner drawn and didn't didn't have
the time yet turn left to to finish this
off yeah okay then there must be a
multiple wins of course it's probably
useless to UM to check them out on
separately let's let's do this year for
example rook h1 and resigns okay
h1z1 I can get the Jeep on okay probably
everything wins what i did also wins
yeah this is some this is the questions
maybe a drawn it's possible but of
course I couldn't couldn't evaluate
evaluate ring yeah now just Kings you
too of course and promotes this is just
ridiculous time time travel move just
kingi two more this is silly nine
seconds is even a fair chance that that
I might might might manage this yeah
okay it's just just a time time issue
and general this is an interesting
opening if you speak German then check
out my video series on this this line of
the caro-kann it's on icc yeah thanks
for watching